[Musique]
voici la boisson qui fait courir les
québécois certains d'entre eux du moins
depuis deux ans ça s'appelle le kombucha
et ça existe dit on depuis plus de 2000
ans julian giacomelli en fait dans cette
usine de saint léonard depuis neuf ans
judicieux moi je faisais beaucoup de
yoga dans le temps donc c'était quelque
chose que j'avais bu à californie et
puis on m'a dit que c'est une boisson
vraiment intéressants pour la santé
surtout au niveau du digestion et ça
qu'est ce que c'est
c'est le principal ingrédient du
cambodge à la tradition veut que la
maman le produit de la fermentation de
thé sucré avec des bactéries et des
levures est été découverte par les
chinois il ya plusieurs milliers
d'années
surnommé le thé de l'immortalité le
kombucha était heureux découvert par les
russes puis par les américains par les
européens et par les québécois ça allait
beaucoup à coloniser le corps a aidé
avec la digestion avait beaucoup de gens
qui voulaient manger mieux qu'ils
voulaient arrêter leur focale troisième
café de boire trop d'alcool
on a vu c'est vraiment un substitut
intéressant pour beaucoup de boissons
certains croient que le kombucha
renforce les défenses immunitaires
réduit la tension artérielle et peut
même guérir le cancer
bref vous l'aurez deviné le kombucha est
devenue la potion magique des temps
modernes
c'est un aliments fermentés qui amènent
des bonnes bactéries des bonnes leveurs
qui vient diversifier le microbiote et
pour ça oui c'est intéressant mais de là
à être lus et des bienfaits pour la
santé
on en pologne une chose est sûre c'est
la manne pour des entreprises comme vice
comme butcher qui a agrandi et
automatiser ses installations pour
produire plus de dix mille litres de
kombucha par jour presque une bouteille
sur deux au canada a vendu d'autres en
moto c'est le round 3 occupe une place
non négligeable dans les réfrigérateurs
des épiceries mais la concurrence le
talonne ici plus que partout ailleurs au
canada puisque le kombucha a su gagner
le coeur des québécois
c'est au québec où les consommateurs
sont sur le plus curieux qui sont en
fait qu'ils sont prêts à acheter un
produit pour la première fois entendu
toujours presque 50 % de novembre
toujours au québec donc ça sert heisman
pour nous selon certains analystes le
marché mondial du kampuchea connaîtra
une croissance de 25 à 30 % par année
tout simplement parce que les grandes
entreprises que le kombucha cherche à
remplacer
les molson coors et pepsico de ce monde
se lance elle aussi dans l'aventuré ici
maxime d'apprendre à du canada mon rêve
[Musique]